[Music]
and just to serve news submitted by
Irene martinsia Crowley has been
sentenced to seven years in prison who
he's the troll guy who bought the drug
company Oh remember when he jacked up
the price to like seven hundred bucks or
something all first people were like
this is Cass of Troy he's in jail oh but
then he was also giving it away oh yeah
so I can't remember exactly was ales
AIDS drugs yeah back in 2015 you made
headlines because he did raise the price
for this one particular drug I was used
to treat AIDS patients the pregnant and
elderly damn aids pregnant and elderly
sounds like a three-in-one Nintendo game
that's like a Tylenol yeah so he raised
it by 5,000% yeah that's when he first
made headlines and then he kept making
headlines for having a big-ass mouth
like just always talking [ __ ] and like
just bragging that he has all this money
and he likes wu-tang and he bought this
this would take a blow he was trying
though just like he wasn't for real well
I I don't know I just I just like to
look at everything through that lens so
my understanding is that he bought the
wu-tang album as a troll move which is
pretty funny he bought it for two
million at an auction you mean the
original is [ __ ] like the master
elbows a signed album oh he got arrested
for child porn no oh he made a lot of
false claims to his investors and pretty
much like for fraud oh ho ho so he got
in trouble for that company dumb-dumb
but it was troll fraud it wasn't real
fraud what's the difference I thought
all fraud is know if you're frowning but
it's through the walls and it's okay
completely okay come on different thing
you should learn the law a lot better
yeah and everyone takes everything so
seriously nicely lighthearted fraud
that's a little murder it's a practical
joke it was a prank it's a YouTube prank
guys yeah so you to prank it makes it
okay when you say that it's a prank bro
yes so his lawyers are asking the judge
to impose a 12 to 18-month sentence
after he was found guilty but the
prosecutors were seeking at least 15
years it turns out though it's
reported that he got seven years instead
and so apparently his lawyers are trying
to get him in a nice cushy like federal
prison but then since he first got
arrested he was out on bail this entire
time he tweeted out something along the
lines was like I will pay five thousand
dollars per strand of hair that off of
Hillary Clinton's head and it has to
have the follicle on it and so that the
judge said the threat yo it was a threat
and so I keep that he is how many hairs
snatching attempts were there after that
I don't know no I mean if he's not known
to be a funny person yeah but he kind of
is you have to do the know the context
of it all man he was trolling a lot on
his Twitter okay so if he's already
doing this on a regular but I don't know
I don't know what it all is man if he's
already under the radar all right under
the microscope not the radar fees I know
the microscope what's my microscope an
optical instrument used for observing
small objects why do anything to attract
any sort of negative attention because
that's how he is he's a troll man at
heart and then thanks to the him being a
troll you're not getting federal prison
and he's getting high-security prison
there is a price to me he's gonna get
and he was crying he was crying
of course you cried you got seven years
I'd be cry my eyes out but is just funny
coming from him though cuz he's such a
like oh cool that's really you never
want to cry on he looks like [ __ ]
Pepe the Frog dude it's a functional
face because himself said sometimes I
just want to punch him in the face like
he [ __ ] there's a bunch of them you
know what this reminds me of the reason
why I like this so much there are so
many people that had that you don't mean
where they know that they won't get
socked too smug to - yeah yeah and it's
so yeah the smell mentality of it all
you know so he don't walk around say
what they want do what they want cuz
they know nobody's gonna [ __ ] them up
but in prison
you're just a [ __ ] piece of [ __ ] yeah
give it you [ __ ] in the ass so what
about the people that are this way and
they do get [ __ ] up but they could it
doesn't faze them and they continue I
think they're gonna continue to get
[ __ ] up mmm
or because he's so [ __ ] rich even
after this [ __ ] he's probably just gonna
say hey when I go out I'll just do give
you guys money just don't touch me
then he's gonna run the prison okay well
this one he doesn't really have much to
offer anymore because prosecutors moved
already to seize he still has money
somewhere else million dollars that's it
yeah he's got offshore investments seven
point four million to him is a [ __ ]
penny that is nothing what did he well
like do you know how he got rich or
anything like that I'm just so curious
how like where he came from yeah cuz
he's like such a stereotypical
antisocial idiot where it's like he's
one of those guys that are so [ __ ]
smart but so [ __ ] human dumb that he
probably figured it out like some genius
way to make a lot of money but he's
probably like those [ __ ] nerds that
got picked on all his life yep didn't
have any friends and now he's like Nate
nerd Rajon yeah he looks like that well
the first day of present for him to get
his teeth smashed in I like I look like
I could just sit here and just we could
all just do this thing was like good
good yeah I love this but I like to do
the other side always right so I'm
trying to figure out like how what's my
angle on this thing
so it's like okay like vaguely remember
something about how like when he bought
this drug this drug was going to go off
market anyway and he bought the drug to
keep to keep it alive to keep it from
going like because it was a very small
drug for a small market group of people
or some [ __ ]
I I think it's so easy to just go this
man is a devil person villain person
right but that's so easy right like I
like how easy is it to I mean we know
the easy to label people it's so [ __ ]
easy [ __ ] I was they could take all the
shady clips on YouTube and [ __ ] evil
I don't dislike them because of all the
drug stuff I didn't know about this [ __ ]
I just basically this picture pop of his
face I just basically all this [ __ ]
picture no cuz I know that that people
were writing him about the the drug and
he was like through her example that
I've seen of him giving it to them for
free so it's not just oh look I'm not
saying he's a great guy or anything I'm
just saying
man it's so easy to go caped villain
boris and natasha [ __ ] evil person
but that's a lot more fun though we need
our scapegoats in society it's true like
look at this [ __ ] look at this Hitler
let's find a pile on it is but yeah look
at that
propaganda ass picture high right there
that's all I need
yeah he does have that look at that look
at that look at that he's preparing for
the punch already ya know he's asking
for it and he just has a magician look
about him that you know you want to be
exactly he looks like he has a Top Cat
like a top hat at a cape for sure he
looks like he practiced his [ __ ]
throwing doves out of his sleeve and so
he he what so he was known for that drug
thing and that's why people hate him
yeah but he was he kept himself relevant
by just being a little he was trolling
all over the place online a ton of it
ton of it so that's why I know a little
more than the the surface see he was
evil thing like I don't know I think
what makes him look even worse is that
he was being shady with his investors
sure I don't know man this is so easy I
completely forgot about that [ __ ] I was
just looking at his picture that's it
that's true cuz if we don't know the
person I know we're just relying on the
media to tell us when who this Quinn
PewDiePie guy called the Nazi and all
this [ __ ] and like he's the most hated
guy on YouTube right now it's like well
there's a little more of that we did
that on jakie news and we [ __ ] up
because we didn't we got the news we got
it from that and then we didn't even
tell the story right because we didn't
we got it from the [ __ ] media well so
we only and that's who who promulgates a
story that Martin shkreli just wants to
jerk off on poor people or whatever like
I'm not saying that he didn't do that
I'm just saying like you know I don't
know man it's just a little easy for me
I don't I don't do we got roasted just
because like you know they want hot
topic so if you want hot topic so we're
not gonna get the best information pick
your [ __ ] poison you want us to do a
hot topic or he wants to chill and learn
about it and then we could discuss it
and then they're gonna complain oh my
god I heard about this story three
months ago can't win so we can only go
up information that you guys are asking
for so you know so it was a weird ground
yeah if you're not a fan like I i watch
PewDiePie videos like a little bit back
in the day when he did like video games
and stuff but if you're not religiously
watching you don't get the humor you
don't get what he's doing and it sort of
Nazi thing like I knew it was trolling
but I did I also knew like you know
PewDiePie should have thought of the
right well how the rest of the world
would perceive that yeah yeah yeah I
don't think I see I think is when you're
doing stick you don't want to think
about what the rest of world thinks you
just wonder your bit and get the [ __ ]
out is he a comedian PewDiePie or is he
just a gamer no he's a comedian
personality yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah I
think he's funny as [ __ ] now I really
did he's better now i I think cuz he's
just doing his own thing now uh-huh like
I used to be like everybody else in like
he just wants to do scary and that ques
wants to be scared and sit in his chair
and pretend to be scared of games or
whatever but but but now he's just
talking like a real person and stuff so
I dig his the way he does that and he
incorporates a lot of like editing and
stuff yes he has a personal style to it
that's what I like about I think YouTube
I wouldn't label them as chameleon or
whatever what are they they're just
personalities right but they have their
own style fighting and then they create
their own it's there's a lot of
creativity behind me but if we were on
the news right now and you said
PewDiePie it's like what the Nazi you're
gonna talk about those not to go labeled
like that's right he's labeled to the
outside world that we're in YouTube so
we know I I see PewDiePie as PewDiePie
the gamer yeah I don't like the great
dancing cuz like even with Logan Paul
right like I've met Logan Paul I work
with Logan Paul and thinning movies like
Logan Paul like I I would have loved to
just go into that experience and like
the way that I was going into it works
like oh great this [ __ ] boy and all and
stuff but when I met Logan Paul he
worked his [ __ ] ass off he tried his
[ __ ] ass off like when he was on set
he was acting his ass off like he didn't
he wasn't like being like Logan Paul
that you think he's gonna be like he had
a dedication and now everyone's like oh
Logan Paul you mean the guy who loves
suicide and can't wait for suicide to
happen your honor it's so [ __ ] easy I
just get bored of it like I want to know
more about the person like did not I
don't want to just demonize
well that's to the ground the suicide
thing was there but then there was like
him and how he treated Japan I think
that's what like did it over the air hey
man I'm not defending any of it I'm not
saying like you know like I think he
definitely made mistakes for sure but
I'm just saying there's more to a person
than like one [ __ ] I [ __ ] up moment oh
yeah a hundred percent obviously yeah
and so yeah I don't like to do all the
great day I don't do it to anybody I
don't like to make fun and dude shtick
and stuff but I don't think the like
yeah he's going to prison or yeah he's
his careers over oh I'm so glad all of
his [ __ ] got cancelled or whatever I
think he deserves a second chance
no that's easy that's easy that's like
OJ right it's like of course he should
rot like that's that's easy [ __ ] like
that that's uh like one thing one
mistake sure yeah I'm like give me a
reason to hang somebody oh you farted
hang up yeah yeah like Oh what what you
accidentally said a bad word hang up I
think loggin was like in the forgivable
State at first and then it just just
started doing this and it uncovered a
lot more but but I will say even even um
the story of monster that Charlize
Theron movie like what's her name the
real lady's name I can't remember her
name but man I watched this documentary
about her and I'm like you know this is
so different than just like hey this
lady is a murderer and [ __ ] can't why
she had a fucked-up life right lean
world
Eileen warnings man so she she had a
fucked-up life she claims that it was
self-defense
that she was killing these guys in
self-defense cuz they were trying to
rape her and then that used to happen to
her all the time as a prostitute and
that's how she made her living and
everyone thought she's trash and she was
like you know what I was defending
myself and I thought you defended
yourself seven times you know hiding
bodies and she's like yeah and she's
like in the cops wouldn't the cops
waited to pick me up or whatever she
said but but there was another side of
the story that I that I liked finding
out instead of just going I lean more
nuts there was a movie about her called
monster she's a monster like it's so
easy like the most hated person in
America I don't know it's just too easy
for me like there's always I like to
hear the other side and then we can burn
them down publicly it's fun yeah I just
don't care enough
I just saw the picture and then I was
like I like your face go to jail like
look at this little [ __ ] hairy mama
give me a reason
[Music]